you've got you you've got man you got
you
you've got mayor goodbye you all of you
who thought a o L was voiced by a
computer now let's set the record
straight I recorded those phrases
welcome you've got mail
files done goodbye my name is Elwood
Edwards and I'm the voice of you've got
mail in 1989 my wife was a customer
service rep for the company that was
about to become America Online she heard
Steve Case talking to some of the
programmers about how fun it would be to
add a voice to the software I've been an
announcer throughout my entire
broadcasting career and she volunteered
me I scribbled those phrases on a piece
of paper and like I say on the cassette
deck I recorded the welcome you've got
mail files done goodbye
it started off as a test just to see if
it would catch on and lo and behold in
the mid 90s it had really caught on and
at one point they said my voice was
heard more than 35 million times a day
but the problem was I was typecast the
one thing I did do was a voice for The
Simpsons
you've got leprosy goodbye being
associated with AOL has been gratifying
even today you go on AOL comm I greet
you I greet myself